welcome back it's time for this week's
pet project
lori herron joins us from the nspca
along with frank marino
and she brought along someone else who
needs a safe and caring home
it's a dog named scruffy welcome you
guys let's start with why
frank is with you in this great
promotion you have going on this august
lori
thanks jc so for the second month
um frank has very generously offered
nevada spca's adopters
two tickets to his fabulous show legends
in concert i'll let him tell you all
about it
yes for everybody that actually adopts a
dog for the next month we did it also
last month you'll get a pair of tickets
to come
see legends of concert at the tropicana
thursday friday saturday 7 30.
uh right now the lineups rod stewart
elvis presley tina turner
and then we switch over and the next one
will be british invasion where we will
have elton john
we will have george michaels and freddie
mercury so a lot of fun and
another incentive to come adopt one of
these amazing dogs yeah so let's talk
about this is awesome first off a great
promotion
secondly tell me about scruffy a little
bit of backstory on scruffy
so scruffy is a 10 year old scottish
terrier and you know what jc we don't
see this breed a lot so it's a really
special breed
he's healthy he's 10 years old he is
um really gentle he's a lap dog
uh he would fit a lot of families that
are watching today and again
you know we don't see a lot of scottish
terriers and he's a little dog so he
still has a lot of life to give and
because he is a senior animal he would
qualify for our senior for seniors
program where
all animals eight and up are free our
adoption fees are waived
steady human seniors that are over the
age of 65 and up and you know what jc he
would be a great companion for watching
tv
or if you need to read a book and i just
wanted to throw in that
there is a great book out there that i'm
reading
you want to talk a little bit about this
you're the first one seeing it on your
show
are you kidding me yes on amazon it'll
be out next week but you could also get
it on frankreno.com
under sensational souvenirs which is my
website but if you get it through my
website you're going to get it one
cheaper and you're going to get it
autographed so
if you want it and you'd like to read
what happened in my life how i did
everything i did and
i tell everybody secrets celebrities and
i also talk about my little dog so
um i love it frank you've got a book out
this is this is breaking news and you
broke it here on las vegas now
we've got to wrap up here but i have to
ask whose house are you at right now
mine uh the statue behind you give it
away i love the statue behind you guys
thank you so much lori and frank we
appreciate you guys have a great day
and if you're interested in adopting a
pet go to
or nevadaspca.org them at 702-873-7722
rocky over to you